Ми прямуємо в сторону Авдіївки - міста, на захоплення якого Володимир Путін уже витратив
понад дванадцять тисяч життів російських солдатів. Бої під Авдіївкою часто порівнюють із Бахмутом.
За нашою інформацією, сьогодні у них планується задіяти 250 особового складу, піхоти
для того, щоб штурмувати наші позиції. І це все на маленькій ділянці фронту.
Грубо кажучи, все це через дві посадки. Нам доводиться такі штурми стримувати саме за допомогою FPV,
тому що відправляти зараз нашу піхоту на зустріч штурму - це дуже великі втрати будуть.
А так ми відправляємо шмат пластику з боєприпасами і просто їх зупиняємо.
Ця рота ударних безпілотників працює всього за 2-3 кілометри від позицій росіян.
Це місце зараз слугує траншеєю. За кілька днів військовим знову доведеться рухатися далі,
чітко усвідомлюючи, що вони самі є головною мішенню для російських БПЛА.
- Ого, скільки їх йде! - А де саме?
Форест, це вони йдуть до Джміля, так?
Основне завдання пілотів ударних БПЛА - зупинити просування живої сили противника і знищити його техніку.
Тому російські військові використовують погані погодні умови для своїх штурмів - коли дрони не можуть літати.
Вони постійно використовують для нас погані погодні умови, використовують для себе в плюс,
тому що корегування відбувається "пташками" - "мавіками".
Росіяни не можуть просунутися технікою, тому що вона вся палиться.
Якщо ви там бачили, то там просто гори, груди спаленої їхньої техніки.
І зараз їм вдалося через погодні умови накопичити значну кількість особового складу,
і вони зараз пробують ним штурмувати, використовуючи погоду.
Тому що, коли, наприклад, ясний день, то в них майже немає шансів.
Втрати несуть страшні. Тому що постійно, типу, що артилерія, що FPV-дрони їх постійно доганяють,
не дають їм висунутися, вони не можуть закріпитися, вони змушені відходити, потім знову приходять.
Відбивати штурми росіян власною піхотою - нерозумно, кажуть військові.
Набагато простіше використати дрони-камікадзе
і зберегти життя своїх побратимів.
Основні мої супротивники - це їхні штурмовики. Їхня піхота, штурмовики.
От, наприклад, коли якийсь іде їхній елітний підрозділ - це, грубо кажучи,
наш пріоритет. Тому що дуже нерозумно виставляти проти
їхнього якогось там елітного підрозділу наш елітний підрозділ.
Ну, ні, вони мають здихати від таких ось штучок. Не треба мірятися,
у кого там краще підготований спецназ, або щось таке.
Краще отаким їх розкидати. І в нас дуже багато прикладів,
де ми прямо таку їхню еліту розбивали, і вся їхня навченість
роками, все вкладене просто нівелюється цією штучкою.
От і все. І вони змушені відступати.
Один FPV-дрон коштує в середньому 500-700 доларів.
Разом із боєприпасом він обійдеться у тисячу доларів.
Тобто можна придбати десь три-чотири таких дрони-камікадзе
за ціною одного артилерійського снаряда.
Та якщо росіянам ці безпілотники видають штатно, то постачання
FPV-дронів для солдатів ЗСУ тримається на волонтерах і донатах, кажуть військові.
У них просто от заходить бригада, і їм у вигляді боєприпасів просто
видається штатно 10000 дронів FPV. Просто от видається, як боєприпаси,
як патрони видається. Вони не думають, де їм взяти це.
А ми думаємо, щодня збори проводимо, ми там їздимо
десь до якихось меценатів, до волонтерів.
Дуже сипле. Я не знаю, що тобі сказати. У тебе пропав зв'язок.
Точно там само. Перелетів, це він впав.
Цей підрозділ за кілька хвилин втратив два безпілотники,
і зараз намагається з’ясувати причину: сталося це
через російські РЕБи чи просто через негоду.
Сьогодні ти можеш літати дуже класно на великі відстані,
а завтра буде подавлення і ти не зможеш, на жаль, …
РЕБ-обладнання не може 24/7 працювати, тому вони або знають,
що зараз їх атакують, вони його включили.
Воно попрацювало годину, дві, три - і його потрібно вже вимикати.
Російська технологія блокування сигналу - це одна проблема.
Інші виклики більш фундаментальні. Вологість погіршує якість сигналу,
а холод зменшує ефективність батарей усіх типів.
Часто звичайні хімічні грілки є єдиним способом,
щоб увімкнути дрони.
Деякі планшети відмовляються заряджатися,
якщо нижче шести градусів морозу.
Ну, взагалі майже вся техніка вдвічі менше працює
або взагалі не заряджається. Ми це намагаємося передбачати.
Ми із собою носимо як свої павербанки,
так і беремо додаткову кількість екофлоу, батарей і стараємося
зігрівати. Наприклад, батареї, з якими ми працюємо, ми беремо грілки,
кидаємо в рюкзачок. Інколи під бронік запихаємо погріти.
Так всьому колективу пороздаємо по кілька батарей під бронік і ходимо.
Коли треба - під'єднали і полетіли.
Щоб здешевити ціну дрона, умільці дедалі частіше роблять для них
раму з дерева чи навіть ДСП.
Цього достатньо для одноразового використання.
Найголовніше в дронах - це їхня кількість. Якщо вони є в достатній
кількості, то в тебе є достатня кількість спроб уразити ціль.
Навіть нам страшно дивитися на це. Ти дивишся зверху - там все всіяне
трупами: вони прямо йдуть по своїх трупах. Прикидаються трупами,
ми їх знаходимо все одно. Я не знаю, що у них в голові,
але, мабуть, їм дуже страшно не виконати наказ.
За рік ця зброя змінила поле битви з обох сторін.
Раніше цивільні дрони вважали іграшками - тепер вони стали
носіями боєприпасів. Дрони паралізують танки,
які довго вважалися ключем до перемоги в боях,
змушуючи їх триматися поблизу укриттів.
Тепер вони нездатні рухатися без атаки згори.
Якщо схрестити снайперку з РПГ, то вийде FPV-дрон.
Саме ця технологічна революція, на думку багатьох, стала на заваді
літньому наступу України. Так само як зараз вона уповільнює
просування Росії в Авдіївці.
Безпілотники вартістю в тисячу доларів, які знищують танки
вартістю в мільйон доларів, стали радше нормою, ніж винятком.
Подивіться, наскільки війна в Україні розкрила те, наскільки всі старі
методи ведення війни і засоби ведення війни,
наскільки вони безтолкові, безкорисні. Зараз увесь світ сидить
і дивиться, що тут твориться, тому що вони на прикладі
війни в Україні бачать, що може спрацювати.
Хід війни змінився завдяки дронам. Зараз завдяки дронам
можна відбити позиції, не втративши, тобто не витратити жодного патрона.
Тобто FPV-дрон може рознести повністю всю позицію,
не застосовуючи навіть піхоти, і просто зайти,
зачистити, хто там залишився, та і все.
Ось лежить один, а он один всередині сидить.
Давати вказівки в таких умовах не просто. Усе вкрите снігом,
а більшість будівель і навіть дерев зруйновано.
І оскільки дрони літають на різних висотах і мають різну оптику,
пілоти розвідників і безпілотників-камікадзе бачать
дуже різні ландшафти. Незважаючи на всі технології,
штучний інтелект досі не замінив людей для такого типу навігації.
Ну, ландшафт щодня змінюється, це явно.
Додається бита техніка, додається ворог, який вже, ну… мертвий ворог.
Тобто ти вже намагаєшся запам'ятовувати, тому що ворог
дійшов до тієї тактики, що він прикидається мертвим,
просто лягає біля мертвого, і ти не розумієш, живий це чи не живий.
Але вже якщо ти щодня літаєш, ти розумієш, ти вже запам'ятовуєш:
той тут уже давно лежить, цей новий. Орієнтуєшся в цьому.
Ось FPV заходить.
Осколочна маса пішла всередину. Тут, судячи з розміру,
до трьох одиниць особового складу може влізти.
Після вибуху руху не було.
Це явне влучання. Двох російських військових спіймали просто неба.
Усвідомлюючи небезпеку, вони прикинулися мертвими.
Але це не допомогло.
Військові кажуть: якщо спочатку до пілотів ударних БПЛА
ставилися скептично, то тепер їхньої допомоги потребують
усі підрозділи на лінії фронту.
Воно того варте, чесно кажучи, тому що скільки життів зберегли
ці пташки, наших хлопців, скільки штурмів відбило,
скільки зупинило, то воно того варте.